my next 17 Challenger is a real dancing
queen Claudia Winkleman how you do great
sort of you are taking this very serious
aren't you yeah I might win you're
cooking the classic 70s dish yes I'm
gonna do my version what's the dish
chili con carne yes see you're gonna
like it
you see a fancy onion it's not gonna do
it these are bananas shalat yeah it
slightly sweeter less harsh on the white
onion yada-yada-yada
I'm gonna use this now don't be offended
I'm going to blend some onion garlic and
straight chilies I'll take the seeds out
because I don't at the time in life now
what are the seventies life for you
favorite food memories would be what do
you know what I like a macaroni cheese
yeah I love macaroni cheese I grew up
with that do you remember something
called ice magic I used to freeze on top
of the ice cream yeah so you should
bring that back what are you serving
with your chili rice do you know what I
like with it
don't say sellers a jacket potato oh
with salutary Matata I can't talk to you
anymore
you laughed at my jacket potato I did
what is this spud you like oh this is
already more tasty than anything you
have ever made what have you just put an
S you're being crazy now that's a
cinnamon stick I'm not gonna try out
that slightly sweetens up the shallows
and baby sweet chili powder a tablespoon
of cumin yeah and a tablespoon of Oregon
oh you're born in 71 72 no side side I'm
actually young
I'm sorry 3300 yeah I guess you were 51
your [ __ ] tone years off it yeah yeah
41 I can't believe you said that could I
just say I love you I'm certainly come
dancing takes two oh thank you
have you met Bruce Lee yes I love Bruce
Lee who writes those jokes me like
couple years ago I was asked to go on
Strictly oh yeah
I said no first of all there's no chance
to get me those tight like a sprinkle of
glitter
every Saturday night oh you were more
boring I can't dance
look at me show me a classic seventies
move I'll watch and learn
deal with me okay what am i doing to you
come on down the tray clip can you do
that
that's it and this up